Good news, horror fans: 2018 is shaping up
to be a banner year for spooky and spine-tingling
video games.
From groundbreaking zombie shooters to vampire
RPGs, there's something for every fright fan
in the new year.
Here's a look at some of the most promising
— and chilling — titles so far.
Overkill's The Walking Dead
Like The Walking Dead's zombie hordes, Overkill's
The Walking Dead is proving very, very hard
to put down for good.
First announced in 2014 with a message from
Walking Dead creator Robert Kirkman, the first-person
survival shooter from the studio behind the
Payday series was originally scheduled for
a 2016 release.
Now it looks like The Walking Dead will finally
shamble onto Xbox One, PlayStation 4, and
PC in the second half of 2018—fingers crossed.
Because Overkill's The Walking Dead promises
not to be your run-of-the-mill zombie shooter.
It challenges players to survive the zombie-ridden
wasteland using a combination of action, stealth,
and resource management.
And like Rick Grimes and his followers, you
won't be going it alone, either—while you
can play solo, cooperative multiplayer will
be the main focus.
"I'm happy to say that it is the, uh, co-op
game that all The Walking Dead fans have been
waiting for."
State of Decay 2
Need more zombie action in the new year?
State of Decay 2 is sure to please Walking
Dead fans — especially those that enjoy
the survivalist aspects more than the gore.
Like the first game in the series, State of
Decay 2 forgoes active zombie hunting and
asks you stay put, hunker down, and build
a base that can protect you and your followers
from the undead horde.
That's easier said than done, and every choice
you make has lasting consequences.
You'll need seeds and equipment to grow a
garden and feed your crew, for example, which
means leading excursions into town to secure
supplies ... which means facing swarms of
zombies.
Maybe you should focus on building a guard
tower instead?
It's up to you.
That kind of variation is what makes State
of Decay 2 so compelling.
You'll never play the same game twice.
Look for this Xbox One and Windows 10 exclusive
in Spring of 2018.
Metro Exodus
The Metro franchise doesn't have the name
recognition of games like Dead Space or Bioshock,
but 2018's Metro Exodus — available on Xbox
One, PlayStation 4, and PC — might change
that.
In a post-apocalyptic world where nuclear
fallout has forced humanity to retreat to
underground subway tunnels to survive, players
fight their way out of a mutant-filled Moscow
and cross the continent in search of a better
future.
Like the previous two games in the series,
players still need to engage in meticulous
stealth-based challenges and fast-paced combat
to survive, and gathering vital supplies is
still a big part of the experience.
But Exodus shakes things up by combining linear
levels with new, open areas for players to
explore.
Bloodstained: Ritual of the Night
If you miss those traditional 2D Castlevania
games Konami used to crank out out a regular
clip, longtime Castlevania producer Koji Igarashi
has you covered.
His Bloodstained: Ritual of the Night isn't
an official Castlevania game, but it might
as well be.
Like Castlevania, Bloodstained stars a cursed
protagonist who explores a spooky castle filled
with demons and secrets.
You'll amass a wide array of weapons and face
all kinds of monstrous foes in your journey,
while robust RPG-like levelling and crafting
systems will ensure that Bloodstained never
gets old.
And yes, while Bloodstained is a Kickstarter-backed
game, which have disappointed in the past,
don't let that turn you off: Igarashi and
his crew say they purposefully delayed the
cross-platform, crowdfunded title until 2018
in order to make sure Bloodstained: Ritual
of the Night lives up to its potential.
Code Vein
Mix Dark Souls with vampires, and what do
you get?
Okay, well, Bloodborne.
Throw in some anime-inspired art, however,
and you end up with Code Vein, an upcoming
horror-action title from Bandai Namco, available
on Xbox One, PlayStation 4, and PC.
Code Vein wears its influences on its sleeve—producers
aren't shy about evoking the Souls comparison,
and why should they be?
Dark Souls' combat is just as thrilling as
it is difficult, and you'd be hard pressed
to find a better model for an action-RPG.
But Code Vein isn't just a knockoff—and
that's where the vampire element comes in.
Players can suck their enemies' blood and
then use the super-charged fluid to unleash
special attacks, buff their characters' stats,
and access all kinds of other supernatural
powers.
Days Gone
If you've ever watched Sons of Anarchy and
thought it'd be better with monsters, then
Days Gone is for you.
The upcoming PlayStation 4 exclusive details
the adventures of a biker-gang-turned-survivalist
group in the Pacific Northwest in an open-world
adventure that takes cues from Tomb Raider,
Grand Theft Auto, and The Last of Us.
As Deacon St. John, you'll traverse the decimated
Pacific Northwest's varied terrain on foot
and by motorcycle, attacking enemy outposts
while making sure your gang remains on top.
The monsters will make that difficult.
Set two years after a plague ravished the
Earth and killed most of humanity, the world
of Days Gone is filled with zombie-like creatures
called Freakers.
Freakers aren't your typical undead foes,
either.
They don't just shamble or shuffle; sometimes,
they run—and they're really fast.
In addition to many human enemies, St. John
will need to outmaneuver and dispatch swarms
of hundreds of Freakers, all while making
sure he's got the resources he needs to fight
another day.
While the specifics of Days Gone's story remain
elusive, the technology on display in the
demos alone is undeniably impressive, making
this one of the most anticipated titles of
the first half of 2018.
Plus, it's likely the only game of the year
to feature a weaponized grizzly bear …
"Just back up, nice and slow.
Don't make a sound."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!